[Applause]
[Music]
king charles and queen consort camilla
were joined by william and kate harry
and megan and the queen's other children
and grandchildren to witness the
coffin's arrival here at buckingham
palace the king wanted his closest
family here with him this evening the
queen's children and her grandchildren
and that of course includes harry and
megan who charles so touchingly paid
tribute to in his debut address to the
nation i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
there's every hope that what will of
course be a very personal
painful and difficult moment here at
buckingham palace for the family will be
another opportunity for the brothers to
reconcile it was after all her majesty's
dying wish
as for harry not being permitted to wear
his military uniform a sussex
spokesperson says his decade of military
service is not determined by the uniform
he wears and we respectfully asks that
the focus remain on the life and legacy
of her majesty queen elizabeth iii
[Music]
you